foreign
[Music]
to the lab Roots webinar where we're
presenting Dr Matthias oolin from the
kth Royal Institute of Technology in
Stockholm where we'll be presenting Next
Generation pan cancer blood protein
profiling using proximity extension
assay my name is Dale yazuki I'll be
your moderator today with a short
introduction about all link
o link if you're not familiar uh with it
is a platform based around a technology
called proximity extension assay it uses
two antibodies and a covalently linked
DNA oligos to increase specificity of
protein detection the beauty of the
assay and technology is that we're able
to Multiplex from the dozens to the
thousands of protein analytes from a
single sample in addition right you're
able to use very small amounts of sample
down to one microliter depending on the
level of Multiplex and in a variety of
formats as you can see on the right we
have o link Explorer with 3000 protein
Targets o-link target which are panels
of 96 or 48 protein targets we have some
15 panels pre-configured in that way all
link Flex which are our newest mix and
match uh product where you're able to
choose 21 targets out of a menu a preset
menu of two about 200
and focus which is a fully customized
product again with 21 markers in
addition we have o-link Insight which is
a data platform for a biomarker analysis
and we'll have a little bit more about
all link Insight later in the
presentation because some of the data
actually from this presentation is on
that particular platform
again the aspect of the PA technology is
we were able to go from Discovery to
clinical translation on a single
technology on a single platform the
Explorer is the 3000 targets like I
mentioned Target with the 96 and then
Flex which is a mix and match
semi-custom panel of 21 markers
and lastly just to to point out the
benefits of the particular technology is
very very high sensitivity in terms of a
multiplex assay exceptional specificity
in terms of knowing exactly what you're
measuring minimal sample volume like I
mentioned one microliter for Target 96
six microliters for o link Explorer and
a very wide dynamic range in terms of
being able to have high sensitivity High
specificity and being able to measure
many logs of dynamic range
without any further delay I'd like to go
ahead and introduce doc uh Professor
Matthias zulin like I mentioned he's at
the Royal Institute of Technology
otherwise known as kth in Stockholm he's
the founder of the science for Life
laboratory which is a Swedish government
um sponsored effort uh and one of the
largest European Laboratories of its
kind
and also since
2002 or 2003 it may have been a typo he
founded the human protein Atlas project
now this has led to over 500
Publications and has spun off several
other atlases since as you can see here
it led to the cell Atlas in 2017 it led
to the tissue Atlas in 2014 the
pathology Atlas and a blood Atlas this
Landmark 2015 paper was one of the most
cited in science where Dr ullin is the
first author and today he'll talk more
about the human disease Atlas which was
the most recent one launched
okay and I think with that introduction
I'll hand over uh the presentation to Dr
Ulin
thank you very much Dale it is a
pleasure for me to give this
presentation about
one of my favorite topics and that is to
talk about next Generation blood
profiling
so with that then I just want to say a
little bit about myself I am actually
not uh there I have about 800
Publications
uh I am as you say the director of human
protein Atlas Consortium so
um with that I just also want to mention
the science for Life laboratory which
I'm very proud of it's a national
infrastructure here in Sweden which is
Big Data technology driven research and
we are actually now in in Stockholm 1200
researchers
so what I would like to start with is to
give you an introduction to the human
protein Atlas this is an effort to
create an Open Access knowledge base for
all human proteins basically and what I
would like to do in this presentation
then is first to give you an idea an
introduction to the first 20 years of
this program then move into the theme of
this presentation which is the next
Generation blood profiling then talk
about the uncancer profiling and then
end by saying a little bit about how you
can access the data which is now an Open
Access resource
so first a little bit about the protein
Atlas it is one of the most visited
databases in the world I should say
biological databases and it is selected
by to be a core resource in Europe
um for for for biology
we have a lot of data in the protein
Outlets we have more than 5 million web
pages which are updated annually and we
also have more than 10 million annotated
tissue images and as I said we have now
published more than 800 Publications
from the Consortium
so um
the flagship paper from the group or
from the program was the teacher Atlas
that was first published in nature in
2014 followed by the science paper in
2015 and this has then been followed by
some other major launches as was
mentioned by Dale the sub cell Atlas in
2017 a cancer Atlas a brain and then in
2021 we moved into the single cell
transcriptomics and just a few months
ago we then released the disease Atlas
so uh the 20 so during these 20 years we
have then done a lot of Milestones as is
outlined uh on the right here but I
don't want to go into that in detail
simply to say that we are trying then to
answer Central questions in human
biology uh what are the uh the targets
for future drugs and Diagnostics how
many proteins are in a given cell and so
on how many proteins are tissue specific
and so on and the way we started doing
that was to build the resource of
antibodies
to all human proteins
we actually decided then to not go for a
recombinant antibodies which are of
course excellent for therapy we are not
going mainly for monoclonal antibodies
which is of course excellent for
Diagnostics and cell sorting but instead
we went for what we called HPA
polyclonals since we are working with
tissue profiling denaturated proteins
and so on and this is actually what we
have used and we actually
we have generated actually it's close to
60 000 antibodies in this way
so um in the version 22 that was
launched in December last year a few
months ago we have a lot of new features
one is that we are actually showing the
structure from alpha fold for all human
proteins
we have introduced a new Multiplex
tissue profiling and we are also showing
a lot of more single cell data and
actually included is also data on more
than a thousand human cell lines
the protein structure section
shows 3D models for all proteins both
experimental structures from pdb but
also imported predicted models from this
Amazing Project called Alpha fall 2.
what is nice about this is that we can
also show on the structure the antonym
binding site for all our antibodies so
we know exactly where in the structure
the different antibodies uh are are
binding
so with that a short introduction I want
to move into the main theme of this
presentation and that is next Generation
blood profiling we are extremely happy
about the technology development that
has happened in the last few years
a few years ago we published a paper in
science 2019 where we had a blood
Outlast but what has happened since then
then is that we now have Technologies
for actually looking also at the very
small and they're very small abundant
proteins in blood
and and that has allowed us now to move
into Precision medicine with the focus
of blood profiling really to start in a
completely new way be able to do early
detection of disease stratification of
patients and monitorial treatments and I
will focus today on the cancer part of
that
we are using as Dale was saying the
o-link Explorer the data that I will
present today is on the 1500 version of
oolink Explorer
and again the this is a fantastic
technology which where you can do
Multiplex assays with high precision and
very high sensitivity with very low
sample volumes
so a few years ago I guess in 2020 we
published a paper where we use this
technology to profile healthy
individuals that we followed for two
years we call it the wellness cohort and
what we showed in this paper that was
published in nature communication is
that each individual that we looked at
had a unique but also a stable plasma
profile so everybody that are listening
now has its own sort of blood
fingerprint
which actually is different from your
neighbor
and this is of course very exciting
we also moved on and looked at the how
many of these protein differences in
proteins
levels are due to genetics we call this
pqtls and published a paper also in 2020
in genome medicine where we actually
identified several hundreds of these
pqtls
um
then we moved on and we looked in
different diseases and this has been
published so I'm not going to go into it
but we looked at type 2 diabetes
patients uh published in 21. uh we have
we're looking at pre-term infants with a
couple of papers in pediatric research
and we also of course looked at covid-19
Patients which was published in 2021
but what we are we were very encouraged
about the results and all the data you
can get out of this amazing technology
so we decided a few years ago to embark
on a very bold project to try to create
a very detailed and comprehensive map of
protein levels in human blood and try to
do that to include most major diseases
create an Open Access resource
identify biomarkers
in in this way
and what we've done is now and we are
finished is that we looked at 88
different diseases spanning from cancers
infections neurobiology
neurodegenerative diseases autoimmune
diseases and cardiovascular diseases so
really try to cover most of the um of
the the uh the major diseases in humans
and of course also healthy individuals
as a comparison
and this just shows you the um we have
analyzed now about 10 000 patients and
we have determined then the blood based
on EDTA plasma to try to be able to
compare between the different chords and
the resource results for all these
diseases will be presented in the Open
Access human protein Atlas I come back
to this
so the first
disease that we looked at is cancer and
the idea then here is to try to see if
we can find a blood profile
that distinguish cancer patients from
one type of cancer from the rest and
also of course to distinguish cancer
patients from healthy individuals and
this is data that has been done by Maria
Bueno Alves and also others in the group
uh I'm not going to go into the workflow
here but simply to say that this of
course involves sample collection we do
a lot of differential expression to
compare the protein levels between these
different cancers then we are also doing
uh trying to create a prediction model
using
AI based models and then also then to
find a protein panel which is ideal and
then classify the cancers unknown
cancers with this model
the differential expression we then
analyzed all the 1500 proteins and I'm
not going to go into the details here
but simply to say that there were quite
a few of these proteins that went up and
down in these different patients
there was overlap in some cases as you
can see here that especially the lung
and colorectal cancers there was a lot
of proteins that
simultaneously goes up in both of these
cancers
or constipations
so basically what we have then moved is
in a sort of a machine learning mode
then uh to try to then see can we find
an algorithm that can sort through all
of this data it's more than 200 2
million database data points and the way
you do that traditionally is that you
have a train set and then you have a
test set and then you try to find what
are the proteins which are most
important to predict if a patient has a
particular cancer and this is what we've
done and this is a rather busy slide but
it shows you uh the results for 12 of
the cancers from leukemia to the to the
left here all the way to ovarian cancer
to the right and you can then see the
population of cancers the levels when
you are predicting with all the proteins
that we have analyzed and in the middle
row here you can see the so-called Rock
curve where you can see how specific and
and sensitive is the assay and we are
very happy to see that in most cases at
least in in the test set then we are
seeing area under the curve of well over
0.95
but you also see in the last row here if
this is called the confusion Matrix that
gives you also the false positives and
therefore's negatives you can actually
see in the red boxes that we are seeing
false positive and false negatives
and this is of course something that I
will come back to uh in the in the last
part of my presentation
but anyway since we're using machine
learning we asked the for an algorithm
to actually can we scale down the 1500
proteins into more convenient panel and
the model then turned out to give us 83
proteins that can then be used to
classify patients from all the different
uh 12 different cancers and I should
point out that the big very frequent
cancers are all included here they're
lung cancer the prostate cancer the
colorectal cancer
and breast cancer
so um with that and here you can see and
this you can also see if you go to the
website you can actually click on these
and see the results for each one of them
I'll come back to this
just to give you a little bit of the uh
the results
uh this is now the some examples or from
the protein panel so you can see on the
top left then that the protein cd244 is
elevated in acute myelody leukemia you
have another protein PA EP that at least
according to us is increased in ovarian
cancer and you have a very nice
elevation of dfap
gfab in in the glioma patients
and and on the bottom row you can see
slum F7 in myeloma you see uh elevation
of the prdx in colorectal cancer and so
on
so and this you can of course also see
in the Open Access resource I I come
back to this
so with this uh we are also
analyzing the classification uh using
this model and the in the panels and
here you can see the area under the
curve in the in the Rock curves for the
12 different cancers if you use all the
proteins which is in in blue if you use
the protein panel which is green and if
you only use the top three
which is yellow and if you only use the
top protein in red and what is very
apparent is that in all cases you get
much better sensitivity and specificity
if you're using the panel as compared to
use a single biomarker
uh it's also of course interesting to
see can we use this to pick out which of
the patients or have cancer and not only
then as I showed before compared with
other cancer patients but also to
compare with healthy individuals and
this just shows you four examples of the
comparison between the health
individuals which is called Wellness
here and then four different Cancers and
you can see that there is a pretty good
distinguishing between and the area
under the curve is in most cases very
very good actually AUC one for the um
for the Alm but oh no for the leukemia
but also a little bit less for the
breast cancer and the lung cancer
so with that then I just want to say a
little bit about the Open Access human
disease blood Atlas so I hope that you
all will go to this uh this is then uh
at protein atlas.org but we also have
the data presented in the whole link
inside that was mentioned by Dave
earlier
so um the um in the protein in the
protein Atlas in the disease Atlas the
protein levels across all the cancers
are shown and you can then see for
example then the flt3 proteins which are
elevated in acute myeloid leukemia as
you can see here and and and this is
then you you we show the data for all
the 1500 proteins that we have analyzed
there's also the o-link inside tool and
we're very happy that all the data has
also been
transferred to the Old Link inside and
there you can actually then go in and
look at the in-depth results for a
specific cancer type
and I urge you all to to explore both of
these resources which are open access
we publish this in a preprint
so if you're interested you can go to
that and read about it it is also in
review right now so we hope to publish
it
um in in the future of course
so with that I just want to conclude
then and
sort of summarize and say that we have
fantastic new tools for comprehensive
and quantity profiling
uh the there is a possibility we think
to identify patients with cancer from
just a small drop of blood
it says 10 milliliter herb it should be
10 microliter of course and the the
version 22 of the urban protein Atlas
which is is is published
contains then the new human disease
blood Atlas so I urge you all to explore
the data by yourself
before I end I want to just also uh say
a little bit about the biomarket Dilemma
uh this is the fact that false positives
are a major issue for population studies
and in this case we're talking about
cancer they are very heterogeneous but
there is also a sort of a rather noisy
biology around the these things so this
means that you will then when you're
detecting a true positive which is
symbolized by the orange person here to
the right you will also
especially if you do a screening method
you will actually also identify false
positive which are so uh symbolized with
the blue persons here to the right
so even if you have a very very high
specificity area under the current maybe
0.99 it will still give you thousands of
wrongly identified patients in in a
screening mode false positives
so this means that if you want to move
into the clinical Arena I think it's
absolutely essential that you have
secondary and independent assays to
identify the false positive then rule
them out so you can then focus on the
true positives but then of course
identify those and start treatment maybe
before you have symptoms actually that
would be ideal
so with that I also want to say a little
bit about the funding this is funded by
a non-profit organization a foundation
here in Sweden called the valenbury
foundation but we also have got a
funding from other foundations like
Norman audits in Denmark Ellen Pearson
Foundation at the heart and lung
Foundation here in Sweden and actually
also have funding from the jeans
foundation
and we are of course also very proud
that we're part of this EU
infrastructure Elixir for sharing the
data resources in an Open Access manner
and so before I end I just want to say
that this is an effort uh which has been
done by a lot of people during 20 years
although the Precision medicine part of
this uh is is focused on the last two or
three years when we are getting this
fantastic new tools to do it I want to
thank Frederick Air Force lymphogue by
Maria Bueno Alves Freddie pontine
especially for all their efforts but
also the other people on this slide
uh I also want to say that during the 20
years of the HPA there has been a lot of
people involved and these are just about
700 people that have been formally
involved to create this resource
so with that I want to keep this to
about 30 minutes and I just want to show
the um
the site where we are the scilaf lab
this is in Stockholm it's at The
carolinska Institute campus the Medical
Faculty and we are at the science for
Life laboratory which you can see to the
far left
so with that I think I want to thank you
for your attention and I hope that you
have uh questions or comments to my
presentation I didn't hand back to Dale
I guess
thank you Matthias for a wonderful talk
uh certainly uh those of you in the
audience if you have questions feel free
to use the Q a box uh to ask your
question
um Matthias if you wouldn't mind
clicking back to that uh code for the
pre-print I thought that was a really
interesting read if I understand
correctly right you looked at some 1500
individuals using o link explorer that
was able to examine these 1463 proteins
and by the way for those listening if
you're interested in that in that
particular human disease uh blood or I'm
sorry human blood disease Atlas go to
protein atlas.org and then you'll see a
panels of all the different atlases that
they have and it's just one click away
as far as choosing the disease blood
Atlas
um a question that I had for you as far
as cancer these particular samples were
not pre-selected for stage right you
just grabbed whatever 1500 samples from
a biobank can you tell me more about the
stage of these cancers and whether or
not it would bias sort of the findings
okay no that's uh so so in this case
we're using a biobank from uppsala it's
called ukam and the good thing about
this biobank is that it has been
collected during 15 years and we know of
course
um old we know the stages when they were
diagnosed we also know the follow-up how
these patients have you know survived
during the years since they got
diagnosed right and all the blood
samples have been taken before they
start treatment which is of course very
important we do have stage information
and in the paper that you can see right
here and there is also a small part
about where we've been looking at stages
because obviously what you would like in
the in for cancer Diagnostics
is to actually be able to to
identify patients already in stage one
or even even zero but uh stage one so
and we can see that in in at least some
of these cases but of course when you're
doing this tongue cancer you're
including 12 cancers
uh you can't have uh too many patients
analyze so that's why we are not
following up this study with another 10
000 patients in order to validate the
results and see that what we found
and we will then use the new panel from
all link which is the 3000 panels so
we're very excited about this I should
also say that I have focused here on the
cancers
but also the other diseases have are now
being analyzed and we will release them
again in a sort of Open Access
manner when we have them analyzed and
checked and validated and so on so you
will then be able to compare the protein
profiles in this cancer with the protein
profiles of obese people of people with
infectious diseases or even
neurodegenerative diseases
sure and as far as then the findings
right I naturally you can't be an expert
on all diseases and all the biomarkers
of these diseases but protein biomarkers
in cancer were studied extensively in
the 90s I mean
I was one of them right working on
melanoma in the 90s and and just doing
right just Western blots on a single
protein Target for those who are experts
in the cancer biomarker field were those
findings unusual surprising or for
example the colorectal cancer markers
did it cover sort of well trodden ground
as well as some surprising findings
they are certainly surprising in that in
some cases and certainly very expected
in some cases so the main biomarker for
glioma for example is a very well-known
brain protein
there are also for the ovarian cancer
it's it's a well-known female proteins
other proteins are expressed or or
produced in the liver so this must be
secondary effects and some of the
proteins are intracellular so they are
obviously leakage products probably so
so it's um it's uh it's a little bit
um but it it is all maybe I should also
say at this point that the the
sensitivity uh is so amazing compared to
what we had 10 years ago I'm sure that
some of you that are listening to this
remember the trial the Serranos trials
with Elizabeth Holmes just a few months
ago where she claimed and the company
claimed that they can do you know 100
assays from a small drop of blood and
that was of course uh uh fake
and here we are and we can do 3 000
assays just 10 years later from a small
drop of blood with exquisite
sensitivity uh and and so so it is an
enormous Revolution that is happening
right now in this field you heard it
here first folks we're living through a
revolution right and you know who uh
less to say it than the person who
founded the protein Atlas way back and
the sort of with all the excitement of
the Human Genome Project I mean in in
along those lines lines right in terms
of such a wider lens that you're looking
at and like you mentioned you know these
unexpected findings I really appreciate
how you closed in terms of looking at
screening applications and false
positives and false negatives and
naturally you have to get disease
prevalence in there as well so it's a
complicated uh set of considerations
right in terms of positive predictive
values and all that one question though
came in in terms of looking at
validating the a being secondary assays
would you say in the screening context
for cancer it would be sort of uh just
conventional diagnostic techniques right
that you would look at someone possibly
right screen for cancer and then they
look at it via regular Diagnostics can
you comment on that
absolutely so I mean fortunately we do
have quite a lot of screening procedures
for some of the more common cancers so
obviously for if if you if you have
breast cancer you are screened I mean at
least in many countries your screen with
mammography if you have colorect if you
look for a colorectal cancer you would
have uh you know colonoscopy or a or
blood in feces and so on so the way I
see this is that you will probably not
screen if you don't have a very sort of
good screening methods that can come
come afterwards but I think we're in
very good we're quite fortunate that
many of these very common cancers we do
have these kind of of the secondary or
screens so instead of you know code
calling in people maybe every 10 years
or so you might then want to do a simple
blood test every year
to actually select those that should
come in for a proper mammography if it's
breast cancer or a or a lung scan if
it's lung cancer and so on yeah so so so
and and and and and this would then
solve this really big dilemma that I
talked about the false positive dilemma
well certainly in the last I don't know
this now
2023 so say the last seven or eight
years with entities like Grail and
Gardens and freenom looking at CT DNA
other small startups looking at
circulating T cells uh or I'm sorry yeah
cancer T cells uh I'm sorry ctcs in
terms of circulating tumor cells Dale
get get it right
um how do you view this in terms of of
the protein findings versus DNA findings
do you see room for complementarity
there or would you say that the
predictive power of such Multiplex
findings you mentioned 83 proteins being
able to segregate out very cleanly 12
different cancers at once can you
comment on that
no absolutely that's a very good
question so so obviously if you look at
the DNA or RNA based methods they are
extremely complementary to this so like
grain for example so I could see that as
a parallel assay that you do but but I
would still think that if I if we found
the breast a potential breast cancer
patients I will still would like that
patient to go through mammography in
order to really establish if you have a
cancer sure sure but but but uh but I
also want to say that this is just the
first study and we all know about
biomarkers and how noisy data is and so
on so even if we have analyzed
altogether now 10 000 patients it is
still when you are actually saying for
each disease it's not that many patients
and so we need to continue and the
community needs to uh do this and this
is one of the reasons why we are putting
out this in an Open Access manner so
people can get inspired and also do
their own studies what a tremendous
resource I mean what remarkable active
generosity as well right to make this
these kind of data sets what some 2
million data points available and on
that note regarding the uh HPA project
one question here is absolutely relevant
do you plan to get into rare diseases
so yeah that's a very good question so
the the protein Atlas uh has up till
basically now been focusing very much on
normal healthy individuals healthy
tissues uh blood in normal uh you know
healthy what we are doing now is we are
moving into the diseases but we have
focus on the big diseases understood
yeah but I I it it is of course
interesting to also go for rare diseases
and and so on but the Focus right now is
to create the resource for the major
diseases that can not only be used to
get inspiration what is interesting
but also gives a reference for people
that are sort of analyzing a specific
type of focus example rare disease then
sure now you mentioned disease
heterogeneity and I know in one of your
slides you talked about being able to go
into other diseases and one question
came in specifically with regarded
neurological disorders specifically
Alzheimer's and it's heterogene you know
native heterogeneity the real importance
for blood-based biomarkers I don't know
if you can comment either on the ad
example or perhaps give us a hint in
terms of what the next sort of disease
area would be
no but I mean we have uh analyzed now ad
patient Alzheimer's patients uh
Parkinson's patients ALS patients and so
on uh also actually schizophrenia and
bipolar patients
so these will be actually presented
uh but I fear just like you're saying
that the heterogeneity will not be much
higher than what we are finding for the
cancer patients but right actually we
don't know yet
we have the data we need to analyze it
and we will hopefully then publish the
um results relatively soon but then we
would like to follow it up with more
patients of course sure very important
diseases sure uh one question that is
interesting right is as far as thoughts
on adoption of this clinically right in
terms of translating it into wider
spread testing do you foresee that are
you optimistic or pessimistic by that I
mean it becomes a technology a
commercial you know regulate regulatory
it's a multi-faceted difficulty and
obviously you're working on the blood
Atlas right for non-invasive testing
right or minimally invasive testing and
the whole goal is to improve move health
care right to improve you know human
health what are your thoughts on you
know it's translatability if I can use
that word of translating into the
testing environment
well first of all I maybe I should say
that we're collaborating with a company
here in Stockholm where you actually
take a blood sample at home and you send
it by mail in a sort of a dry blood spot
uh sort of format
which allows people to actually then
sample themselves at home and send send
them with mail to the lab and get the
results
uh but so this is this and and we have
excellent results from this and it it
seems like it's uh as good as if you're
using the sort of standard EDTA plasma
from from from
people so so but of course
uh we would like this to be translated
into the clinic but as you say there's a
long way to go it's it's you have to
validate uh probably we would like other
researchers to join in and actually do
different diseases maybe in a more
targeted way and what we are doing is
this pan disease which of course is
interesting as a sort of basis for this
but it's probably not enough to actually
be bold enough to go into the clinic uh
you have to then validated in larger
cohorts yeah also maybe
um in in in
longitudinal cohorts and also then with
a lot of healthy individuals yeah but
saying that
I mean when I'm looking at the data and
you can all look at the data in this
publication
I I really think this I I would be very
disappointed if you can't translate this
or similar into the clinic in in the
future well when you see yeah go ahead
yeah
there is especially for cancer
if you find a cancer early on I can give
you an example breast cancer you have 99
chance of surviving if you find it at
stage one
and you have only 20 to 30 percent
chance of survival if you find it at
stage four
and obviously if we can have this type
of screening find cancers early on
absolutely I mean it would save so much
uh cost to society but also save a lot
of lives so so I I I'm very much hoping
that this can translate but I also know
that it's naive to say you know it's
it's three or four years uh right we'll
see yep it becomes a difficult problem
right when you're looking at say pan
cancer and looking at so many cancers at
once it becomes a real uh practical
problem but at the same time you look at
those aucs that you showed and you see 1
and 0.99 and 0.98 just say these are
remarkably discriminatory right being
able to detect cancers being able to
detect I think the unusual approach in
your in your work right was that you
were looking for The Unique signature of
each of the 12 cancers right it wasn't
just cancer or not it was each
individual cancer and on the machine
learning side there was a question that
came up regarding thresholds right yeah
in your machine learning model it was a
data model right that combined these two
million data points and these 1500
samples in the 1463 markers all into
what can discriminate versus not uh can
you comment on that in terms of like you
know the threshold cutoffs and I I guess
it gets back into the fact that you had
historical data on patient outcomes with
the 15 years of data on these samples is
that correct
no in this case
the the the the allegory or the machine
learning and and this was uh an
algorithm called glimnet that we use we
also been looking with random forests
and others but what we are basically
asking the the
um the the the the machine learning is
to go to the 70 diff 70 of the of the
samples I'm trying to find a profile
that would identify one cancer from the
other 12 cancers as good as possible and
then you're just checking this on the
unknown well for the algorith unknown
samples which is 30 but obviously it
would be now extremely nice to test the
algorith on a very independent cohort
and this and it would be interesting to
you know combine in this with the
community where people are doing these
kind of work and then we could actually
use the algorithm to actually analyze it
further and validate the results
right and going back to for my last
question going back to some of your
first slides where you reviewed some of
the work from the escapists
longitudinal cohort that you had what
you had uh pqtls coming out you had type
2 diabetes you had a pre pre-term infant
birth and they had covid I mean it
seemed like that longitudinal cohort
just was a fountain of all kinds of
interesting research is that work still
going on do you still have more uh
places to investigate with that
longitudinal cohort and also what does
that uh imply for other cohorts by that
I mean the importance of longitudinal
Wellness testing so to speak or Wellness
sampling and following individuals over
time
yeah no it's very interesting and as you
as you say the what we are what we are
finding in these cases I I'm just gonna
show you this uh no I didn't show any
results from this it is of course in the
in the papers uh but the fact is that
each one of us seems to have when we are
healthy uh a very stable fingerprint of
blood and when we get diseases and we
have for example one person that uh
did lose a lot of weight uh we had
another person that got a serious
infection and so on then some of these
profiles you know just goes very
different so
so I think that what we are seeing is at
least signs that it would be very good
to maybe do uh screening you know every
year or so and look at the blog profiles
and you know see do you have cancer do
you have other diseases but again
the false positive dilemma is something
that has to be addressed all the time we
are not out to make people you know
to to to make people worried we want to
help people and the false positive
dilemma is is is of course not uh nice
but the pro the nice thing about
longitudinal studies is of course that
you can compare your profile with your
own profile one year earlier or so which
of course is also very nice compared to
actually comparing your profile with the
rest of the population yeah so it
becomes more individual I I think what
you point out is the the real-time
nature of proteomic or protein testing
in blood right is that it's an accurate
real-time indicator of General Health
and then if you had a baseline for
individuals right and like you say when
things start going awry when signals
start to change how powerful that can be
but
like you mentioned so many individuals
so much individual variation right
that's driving protein determination you
know how does that all start but we
start somewhere you're going to say
but it but but again I must also stress
that sometimes too much information is
not good for for for us yeah and for so
so one has to I think one has to be very
careful what you're actually analyzing
I'm not a very big believer that in the
end your test for everything because if
you test for everything you will always
find something and if you find something
you have to do something about it yeah
yeah and and in most cases it might not
be clinically relevant so I think it is
very important that we know what we are
doing in the end and why
well I want to thank you uh Matthias for
your generosity and sharing these things
today certainly
um the questions that we're not able to
be asked we will address individually
via email and thank you very much for
joining us today
thank you very much great